i love being a mom it is by far the
coolest job in life
and i do look forward to having more of
those sweet little angels
and it'll happen at the perfect time for
sierra's growing family
the time is now
the 34 year old singer and husband
russell wilson have welcomed baby number
three in the family
a boy the little one joins
three-year-old sienna
and ceara's five-year-old son futures
the here whom she shares with her
ex-fiance
rapper future the level up singer
announced she was expecting a third
child back in january
with this shot while on vacation in
turks and caicos
in april the then family of four took to
instagram with a cute gender reveal
video
and one month later ciara told e.t how
excited her little ones were
for a baby brother they talk to my belly
every day or at least every other day
and they are pumped uh future was really
happy that it was a boy
cece and me gonna represent for the
girls
i follow princess she'll be surrounded
by boys she's got so much attitude and
so much sass that she
could be the one girl that makes up it
all honestly um but yeah it's
it's um it's super exciting throughout
sierra's pregnancy the mom of three has
been rocking and flaunting
her growing belly even captioning this
photo
the bump is bumping i will give my
husband a lot of credit and think that
he makes me feel sexy
you know through throughout the whole
journey like whether his belly's growing
and then belly's going back and that
skin is like
you look in the mirror like what is
going on like okay when is my skin i'll
get back normal but he always tells me
i'm beautiful
not only did sierra keep fans updated on
her baby bump
she also shared her journey as a quote
pregnant woman in covet 19 era
revealing the new process for doctors
appointments russell
facetiming her from the car for the
baby's ultrasound
that was like a really significant
moment i think in all of this
that really mark a time of where i am in
my life as a pregnant woman
and so i couldn't help but think about
everything else the amount of people
that can come in the hospital during the
birth has been limited
so i'm like wes is going to be not only
dad but he's going to be the
videographer and the photographer
the power couple started dating in 2015
and tied the knot a year later
with a stunning wedding in an english
castle
in 2019 the singer and nfl star opened
up to e.t
about the secret to their happy marriage
i think the most important
thing is first of all just loving one
another you know for love you do it you
do anything and you take care of one
another and i think communication
you know there's always communications
there's lows and everything else but
communication is everything and
i think that when we were able to do
that and take care of your kids and
everything else it's a lot of fun so
we get to do it